foreign
in fact if you run through the inventory
of the most successful ideas of the last
50 years in physics almost all of them
have a natural home within String Theory
what Brian talks about is a string
theory sort of self-invalidated in the
early 2000s
people will continue to work on any
given subject so long as it continues to
bear fruit and give interesting results
that Inspire yet other avenues of
research and that's what's happened in
string theory and that's why people have
continued to work on it and when the
theory and the ideas begin to dry up and
they're no longer bearing fruit then
individuals will move on and certainly
some string theorists of the past have
moved on to other ideas because they
lost interest in this or that Avenue of
research the fact is is that string
theorists will always tell you that if
the better Theory came along that they
would immediately move to it but when
you ask them about whether they've
looked at their colleagues theories if I
ask Brian for example how in depth have
you looked at Peter White's assertion
that you should start from the Oddity of
su3 go back to su4 and look at a twister
Theory which includes Wick rotation at a
fundamental level I don't think Peter
White's theory is correct but at least
I've looked at it very often the string
theorists will tell you that they have
no time so what you start to understand
is is that there is a very easy set of
behaviors in in an Equanimity that the
string theorists appear to have that is
not realized except in the breach so the
problem that we usually confront is is
that this Theory plays by sociological
and and economically different rules
um if you say for example that there's
no experimental test of string theory
yet many string theorists told us
exactly where we would find relatively
low energy supersymmetry at the LHC
which failed to materialize and so you
can play infinitely the the energy the
energy dog ate my energy homework the
particles are never found if you push
string theorists hard enough they will
say well it's actually not a theory but
a framework when I pushed Joe polczynski
of blessed memory on this point he said
Eric you treat String Theory as it's a
as if it was a theory when I think we're
just running subroutines for Ed being
Edwinton it's a very strange game and
not at all how science is played so I
believe that Brian is making a better
Point than Roger no offense but I
believe that the point is actually that
you're playing keep away according to
rules that always favor String Theory
it's like why you don't win in Vegas
it's because the house is always taking
it's it's Vig and you can't possibly win
and so the problem here is that what
sounds reasonable is reasonable at the
first level but then you know I would
ask Brian
um you know what do you think about my
explanation for why there are three
generations of flavor chiroparticles I
doubt you probably even know that I have
an explanation and it might be wrong I'm
not afraid of being wrong but my feeling
is I've studied your work I've studied
your books your PBS specials and there
is no reciprocal interest because this
community secretly thinks that it is
smarter than the other communities and
in general this is in fact true I'm not
arguing it
what I am claiming is that that level of
intelligence has been misspent and it
has been directed by a tiny number of
individuals string theory is not in some
sense dominant at the moment but the the
pig went through the pythons in the 80s
there were a huge uh number of jobs many
of us were critical at the time I moved
into mathematics to avoid this thing and
in fact what happened is that that Pig
is working its way through the python as
an affirmative action program for
Boomers and Silent generation
academicians who are exceedingly good at
mathematics but seemingly not so good at
physics and I do of course remember the
period you're referring to Eric back in
the 80s and I do feel bad that some
wonderful mathematicians and physicists
who were not working on string theory
found it difficult to get jobs and to
get post-docs I remember talking to
Peter white back in the 80s I gave a
talk at Stony Brook and he was working
on some very interesting stuff but the
jobs weren't materializing in a way that
perhaps he deserved and it wasn't
happening and the problem is it's a
finite resource I wish we would just
take half of the budget from the defense
departments around the world and turn
those into academic jobs for physicists
mathematicians poets literature
specialist language but I mean that's
really where the culprit is a main brain
but the problem is is that the the
invective that was leveled from your
community towards the other communities
is the part that's ignored so that's the
part Eric that that I'm I was there and
again I wasn't in every room so I I
certainly and can't claim to say that
that didn't happen if you were the
recipient of that kind of invective I
will apologize on on the part of the
community because that's never anything
always been you've always been the most
decent of string theorists but no as you
can see I have no problem agreeing with
Brian when he's right and he's often
right the problem is is that Brian is
not representative of a community that
refers to others as morons as idiots as
wasting their time as uh not really
physicists etc etc ask any postdoc who
passed through Stanford during its
period of Maximum Euphoria for string
theory people come out very broken and
angry I remember David Kaplan giving an
interview David E Kaplan because there
are two of them where he said it took
him a long time to realize that he
wasn't an idiot because he couldn't
understand what was being done and was
being told that he was somehow mentally
deficient there was a real problem there
continues to be a real problem Michio
Kaku just said put up or shut up I'm not
aware of Michio kako putting up much of
anything I've put something up and the
guy will not be quiet I mean it's some
level this is an extremely aggressive
belligerent community and unfortunately
we have the most kind and decent
exponent of it so I'm I welcome any
discussion with Brian Greene because
it's fantastic obviously a large
community of thousand researchers is
going to have a big bell curve of those
who are able to play well with others
and those who don't uh I've been called
by some people in the field at
various times it's an unpleasant thing
to have happen and it isn't the way
people should talk to each other so I'm
glad that we totally agree on that
getting back to sort of the um the
physics side of things
um I wish and and you know I'm gonna
Echo have already made reference to but
I'm saying it in a sincere way I truly
wish I had enough time to investigate
the various ideas and theories that are
mailed to me sent to me put in front of
me and the problem is very hard to carve
out the time to investigate Theory after
Theory after Theory especially when I
don't even have time to keep up with the
rapid pace of development within String
Theory proper itself so it's not it's
not let me just let me just finish one
point it's really not that I have no
interest in other ideas and other
approaches and I would say that that's
pretty much true of many of my
colleagues as well
the the problem is it takes so much
effort and time to even understand the
language sometimes in which other
theories are described or to go through
manuscripts of dozens 50 60 pages of
calculations it could take weeks and
months to really get to the bottom of it
and that's really what the problem is so
what I would say is by no means am I
going to Echo Michio kako's put up or
shut up because that's as you said
that's not sort of my frame but if
another theory came along and did say
what String Theory did for understanding
of general relativity and quantum
mechanics which is where the interest
came from it solved a problem that that
nobody had any idea how to solve before
and it did it in a in an understandable
and manifest way that you didn't have to
work very hard to understand the
progress and you could jump in at the
ground floor and run with it if there's
a way even of your theory being put
forward in a way that says here's the
problem that I've solved here's the way
it's consistent with everything that's
come before here's the advance it's
going to give and all you need to do is
understand these three ideas yeah I
would be open to learning about it so
absolutely okay so first of all
appreciate it uh I appreciate the
sentiment uh what you're saying is that
string theory solves a problem interior
to quantum gravity which really
originates around 1952-53 with Bryce
DeWitt my feeling about this is if
space-time is in fact doomed as is
fashionable to say it's not clear that
the way of harmonizing gravity and the
standard model is to force gravity into
submission into a Quantum regime it may
be that in a not in a post space-time
construct harmonizing gravity rather
than quantizing it is important and what
happens with the string theorists is
that they very frequently say we've come
closer to a quantum theory of gravity
when you get to that point please give
us a ring and some of us are saying you
actually haven't made the case for
quantum gravity which has been 70 years
trying to ship a product and failing
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas